The Ethics Committee is
one of the SCP Foundation's
most important and overlooked divisions.
The small, secretive group keeps a close eye
on the Foundation to ensure that all decisions
made and all actions taken are for the betterment
of humanity, and not just in service of needless
sadism and cruelty.
The Ethics Committee consists of a small group
of people in comparison to the gargantuan
that is the Foundation as a whole.
It’s only natural that every so often something
slips under their radar.
And when it does, it usually results in complete
and utter disaster.
In the case of SCP-4051, that something is
a male humanoid with a unique ability to open
wormholes to extradimensional spaces.
And in terms of disaster?
Well let’s just say we hope you have a pretty
tight grip on that red SCP Expert coffee mug
of yours.
The wormholes that SCP-4051 opens are essentially
spaces filled with infinite copies of a single
item, which SCP-4051 can reach in and pull
out - assuming they're small enough that is.
The Foundation's strict experimentation schedule
has provided a lot of important data on how
SCP-4051's anomaly functions.
Controlled testing showed SCP-4051 was able
to manifest small, simple objects like a net,
sugar pills, or drinking water.
But he's also claimed or reported to have
manifested many other things, like aluminim
baseball bats, duct tape, and more.
At one point, SCP-4051 was allowed to use
these abilities to assist with the site, but
the Ethics Committee recently halted this.
Seems like a simple enough anomaly, but with
the Foundation, we all know - it never is.
So let's go back - let's start at the very
beginning.
The Foundation first became aware of SCP-4051
when YouTube videos surfaced online of a vigilante
in an American city using wormholes to fight
criminals.
The videos got over two million views before
the Foundation became aware in August 2012
and stepped in, taking it down and investigating
what had led to it.
A Mobile Task Force was dispatched to retrieve
the individual using the wormholes, and brought
SCP-4051 back to Site-17.
The first interview with SCP-4051 began on
a bad note.
SCP-4051 was handcuffed behind a pane of glass
when Doctor Arthur Roswell began to speak
to him.
Dr. Roswell introduced himself and confirmed
that SCP-4051's name was Rainer Miller.
After being assured of his safety, SCP-4051
calmed down a little and stopped struggling
with the handcuffs.
At Dr. Roswell's request, SCP-4051 began to
explain the details of his anomalous power.
He affirmed that he could make small objects
appear out of thin air, and that he tried
to use these abilities to help people.
At first he'd intermittently interrupt carjackings
and robberies, subduing the criminal, but
with a new criminal syndicate moving in, the
crime rate sky-rocketed requiring Rainer to
patrol much more regularly.
During these acts of heroism, several witnesses
saw Rainer's powers, though he tried to keep
it quiet.
His request for the Foundation to intervene
with the criminal situation was acknowledged
as Rainer volunteered any and all information
he had, stating that he just wanted to help
the Foundation.
Roswell thanked him for his enthusiasm.
It didn't take long for the Foundation to
move to experimenting with Rainer's powers,
as the Foundation often does.
At first, they started slow.
Dr. Roswell and his colleague, Dr. Edwards,
asked Rainer to manifest a few small items
- a metal cube, a bottle of bleach, and something
of his choice.
He was able to produce the cube without any
trouble, and the object of his choice wound
up being a framed picture of his mother.
When he tried to take the bleach out, he seemed
upset, but managed to do it.
With the experiment a success, SCP-4051 was
escorted back to his containment chamber.
All the way there, he repeatedly asked how
long this testing phase would take before
he would be let go.
The staff didn't have an answer for him.
In the next test, Rainer was asked by Roswell
and Edwards to produce a copy of War and Peace
and a phone.
Both were produced, but the book was filled
with gibberish, and the phone was entirely
hollow.
The researchers concluded that the anomaly
is based on how well SCP-4051 understands
the object being manifested, and mused about
requesting something that didn't exist.
Rainer still asked all of the researchers
how his family was, and whether he would have
any friends at the Foundation between tests.
The questions were, once again, ignored by
the staff.
In the third experiment, Roswell and Edwards
asked Rainer to produce objects that didn't
exist: a circular square, a color, and so
on.
But SCP-4051 wanted to know about his family
and when he would be able to go home before
he would try to manifest anything.
Roswell assured him that once the Foundation
had a solid grip on his ability, he would
be allowed to go home.
Questions about his family revealed that his
mother believed he was away visiting colleges.
He demanded to speak to his mother before
any other experiments, and Roswell affirmed
that he'd ask the O5s for approval when the
experiment in question finished.
Rainer agreed, and began the experiment, trying
to produce the impossible items.
What came out were cognitohazards, severely
damaging the mental state of anyone trying
to perceive them.
Half the research team instantly collapsed,
and security guards subdued Rainer to take
him back to his cell.
The testing chamber was cleaned and Dr. Edwards
wrote that the value of SCP-4051's anomaly
was too great to let him sit in a box unused.
He called for a special pediatric therapist
and authorized further experiments on Rainer.
But in his own containment cell, Rainer was
still knocked out after the test had gone
wrong.
The cameras watched on as he woke up and began
curling up and away from them toward the other
side of the room, then standing up a few minutes
later.
He had manifested many small pieces of body
armor and glued them to his body.
The guards were distracted with escorting
Roswell and Edwards from the testing chamber,
and didn't realize anything was wrong until
Rainer manifested a small bomb and blew his
door open, leaving his cell.
Other security guards immediately turned and
responded, trying to subdue SCP-4051 with
nonlethal weapons.
Eventually, a few were able to overpower and
incapacitate Rainer, and move him back to
his cell.
The day after the containment breach, Site-17's
director, Thomas Graham, sent out an open
letter to all staff assigned to SCP-4051.
Rainer had been moved to a more secure containment
unit, but everyone agrees that it would be
better in the long-run if SCP-4051 is working
for the Foundation rather than against it.
Especially with regards to amnestics.
Sourcing Y909, a chemical used in amnestics,
was dangerous and expensive for the Foundation.
But if Rainer's abilities could be harnessed
to produce amnestics easily, then he would
be all the more valuable to them as a friend
rather than foe.
The Ethics Committee also require that SCP-4051
do so voluntarily for the Foundation, rather
than being forced to produce amnestics against
his will.
To that, Doctor Edwards was promoted to SCP-4051's
Project Director on the basis that he would
try to ensure Rainer would be totally and
utterly loyal to the Foundation, using whatever
means necessary.
He already set up a schedule using punishments
and rewards, along with regular checkups from
an on-site therapist.
The therapy sessions began on a good note.
Dr. Yesenia, the therapist assigned to SCP-4051,
introduced herself politely, and Rainer seemed
to take a shine to her.
They discussed his unique anomaly, and the
containment breach incident.
Yesenia was kind, and understood the psychological
toll containment had on people.
She asked why he wanted to escape, and he
explained he just wanted to see his family.
He was close with his mother, since his father
had walked out on them when Rainer was just
a boy.
They had been supporting each other since,
and he missed her a lot.
That said, he explained he wasn't opposed
to living at the Foundation.
They could help him actually understand his
powers, and he didn't mind being a part of
tests if he knew he was helping people.
He just wanted to see his family again.
Yesenia's after-meeting note said that containment
efforts should be focused on assuring Rainer
that the Foundation had his best interests
in mind.
The next set of experiments were a little
more abstract.
Doctor Edwards alone was overseeing them,
and the first experiment included another
individual, a D-class.
The plan was to see if the D-class could also
pull things out of the portals, or if only
SCP-4051 was able to interact with his portals.
The D-class was scared of Rainer, but after
some urging by Dr. Edwards, he managed to
touch the sides of the portals and reach in
and pull out a stone.
Rainer was only anomalous in his ability to
manifest the portals, so Edwards' plan was
to cut out the middleman, and perform research
on SCP-4051's brain to see
if they could successfully
devise an artificial method of creating the
portals.
The experiment after that was to see the bounds
and geographies of the pocket dimensions that
Rainer generated.
A GPS tracking chip was thrown into one of
the portals SCP-4051 made - specifically the
portal leading to portraits of his mother.
The portal shut, then Rainer was asked to
recreate it.
The researchers checked to see if they could
still get a solid signal from the tracking
chip - and they did, albeit almost a thousand
kilometers away.
The results were filed away, but Edwards noticed
one thing - the portrait of SCP-4051's mother
was slightly different.
It seemed that he was forgetting what she
looked like.
The next therapy appointment with Doctor Yesenia
covered how Rainer felt about that experiment.
He was excited that they were actually performing
research about the anomaly that he wasn't
capable of just telling them, that they were
now finding out something interesting about
his powers.
Yesenia asked if he had any requests for tests,
but he doubted that Edwards would listen to
anything he said.
The doctor seemed to dislike Rainer for some
reason he couldn't figure out, but he knew
best on what to test and how.
Meanwhile, Edwards had come up with something
that could utilize SCP-4051's abilities in
a useful way for the project of synthesizing
amnestics: Procedure 350-PROMETHEAN.
The details of this clandestine project are
murky and secretive, but the goal was to see
if they could use Rainer as a live method
of synthesizing Y909 through an experimental
surgical procedure.
Several contingencies were planned - if the
wormhole became too dangerous or Rainer tried
to resist, he'd be automatically injected
with paralytics and sent back to his cell.
The project wasn't immediately approved, though.
The Ethics Committee sent one of their most
skilled liaisons, Jeremiah Cimmerian, to conduct
the approval process.
He interviewed Dr. Edwards, ascertaining that
the man was sane and able
to conduct the procedure.
That any unethical actions that were outside
the scope of the proposal would result in
his removal from the team and disciplinary
action.
Moreover, he revealed that he knew that Dr.
Roswell, SCP-4051's original researcher, was
Edwards' brother, and that he had been permanently
injured in the incident when Rainer was asked
to manifest impossible objects.
Edwards swore that he wouldn't take any needless
actions to cause intentional pain and suffering,
and that everything that he would do would
be in the service of the Foundation's goals.
With that, Procedure 350-PROMETHEAN was approved.
Meanwhile, Doctor Roswell's condition wasn't
improving.
He had been put into an induced coma by medical
personnel due to his extensive exposure to
the cognitohazards.
He wasn't expected to recover anytime soon.
After the Ethics Committee approved the procedure,
Doctor Edwards stopped
conducting usual experiments.
The very next test involving SCP-4051 was
the first implementation of
Procedure 350-PROMETHEAN,
but it failed.
Rainer broke the restraints on the chair during
the painful procedure, and Edwards considered
tranquilizing him but decided against it:
"we need it awake" He said.
The next therapy session, though, Rainer didn't
so much as mention the procedure.
Instead, he greeted Doctor Yesenia, explaining
that he wasn't doing so well.
He had talked back to a guard and they had
taken his desk away as punishment, and he
felt like it was his own fault.
Doctor Yesenia was worried and offered to
see if she could get the desk back, but he
declined the offer, saying he'd just try to
be better.
After the session, Yesenia felt annoyed - not
by Rainer, but by Edwards.
He had been saying that the subject was getting
resentful and rude, but Rainer still seemed
like a sweet, helpful child.
The next time Procedure 350-PROMETHEAN was
enacted, it was the first time Edwards actually
managed to successfully complete it.
SCP-4051 was actually being compliant with
the procedure, making the job a lot easier
for the surgical staff.
The results and details of it, however, were
still unclear.
In the therapy session after that, Rainer
told Doctor Yesenia that he had been having
terrible, terrible dreams every night.
Nightmares that stopped him from sleeping.
He worried that people would treat him like
a freak - not because of his anomaly, but
because of what had happened with his father.
Doctor Yesenia encouraged him to tell her.
She already knew, but felt it would be good
if he let it out - and he shared his memories
of how his father had locked him in a closet
and abused him, burning him with bleach.
That's why he'd been upset when asked to take
a bottle of bleach in the first test.
His nightmares were about not being able to
escape something that was coming toward him.
And that his father could still be out there.
But Yesenia admitted to him that while she
shouldn't be telling him, his father had been
found by the Foundation.
He was serving a life sentence in an Arkansas
prison for murder.
Rainer grew quiet for a moment before changing
the subject.
Yesenia's observations were optimistic, and
she believed his mental health was improving
and that he was now fitting into his role
at the Foundation, though she wondered how
Edwards' experiments with him were going.
The next implementation of
Procedure 350-PROMETHEAN
went poorly.
Edwards wrote in his diary angrily afterwards,
that Rainer didn't even remember Roswell or
recognize his name.
How he was angry that he was assigned to the
anomaly that had nearly killed his brother.
He'd had an outburst during the experiment
and it was shut down early.
But only a week after, another attempt was
made.
While the procedure was being done, Rainer
asked about Roswell, but was cut off.
The research team knew that if he was told
what he had done to Doctor Roswell, his mental
health would crater and negatively affect
the project.
In spite of that, the procedure was a success,
and Edwards' took credit for the whole thing.
They were getting closer to being able to
completely make use of SCP-4051's anomaly.
In his next therapy session, Rainer recounted
how he liked being out and about in nature,
and how the containment cell had become a
suffocating prison.
Yesenia suggested she might be able to swing
a treadmill in his room to keep him active
if she bothered her superiors, but he didn't
want her to get in trouble.
He seemed worried and upset - he voiced that
he didn't think these experiments were helping
people anymore, that he was being a burden.
Yesenia had an idea - she could ask the Director
to allow Rainer to help out around the site,
fixing little things and helping clean things
up.
It wasn't much, but it would allow him some
activity and boost his morale about helping
people all while making use of his anomaly.
Rainer was excited - he loved the idea, and
had been scared of being stuck in his cell
uselessly.
After the session, Yesenia reflected that
it seemed cruel to manipulate SCP-4051 into
wanting to help the Foundation when he so
obviously already wants to help.
And just like she said, it didn't take long
for the Director to authorize a security clearance
for SCP-4051, just enough to be outside of
his cell when accompanied, to help with site
maintenance.
While Rainer was off fixing things around
the site, Yesenia decided to do some digging,
and asked for information about the experiments
Edwards was conducting, but didn't have a
high enough clearance.
Meanwhile, Edwards had come up with a prototype
for a machine that can mimic SCP-4051's abilities.
A few weeks after it was approved, Site-17
had a minor containment breach and a few hostile
anomalies overran armed personnel.
Rainer was present at the time and used his
wormholes to terminate the anomalies before
containment was reestablished.
Even though he saved lives, Yesenia was forced
to reprimand him for using his powers without
authorization, and he was banned from any
maintenance for two months.
Several months later, the machine to mimic
Rainer's powers, 350-JANUS, isn't working
correctly and keeps producing the wrong object.
Yesenia keeps requesting information on Edwards'
experiments, but is denied every time, even
when she asks the Ethics Committee for a review
on the project.
The machine worked, but only once, breaking
right after.
SCP-4051's story is a strange one - it involved
an MTF mission sent into a dangerous area
to contain an object, with Rainer sent along
with them.
The full mission log has yet to be declassified,
and maybe we'll cover it in a future video.
But for now, let's just say something went
wrong during that mission.
The Foundation discovered something new and
dangerous about SCP-4051's powers, and a closer
eye fell upon the project.
The Ethics Committee reevaluated what had
gone on with SCP-4051, and the Site Director
surrendered information -
that Edwards' experiments
hadn't been all in the name of science.
That he might have been needlessly cruel and
violent to an innocent anomaly, just because
he wanted revenge for the accidental mutilation
of his brother.
After taking a closer look, the Ethics Committee
came to the decision that SCP-4051 needed
to be re-thought.
Large portions of the document were redacted
and classified, and they tried to bury the
project.
SCP-4051's powers were too dangerous to allow
about the site - his permissions were revoked,
and he was placed into permanent containment
in a more specialized cell.
The researchers of the Foundation need oversight.
Otherwise, you get incidents like SCP-4051,
where a vengeful doctor subjected an otherwise
innocent being to brutal surgical experiments
and manipulation under the guise of research.
It goes to show that the Foundation isn't
always the good guy - in
fact, from the perspective
of the anomalies, the Foundation can be pretty
damn evil.
Now go check out “SCP-4999 - Someone to
Watch Over Us Tale” and “SCP-999 - The
Tickle Monster” for more anomalies of the
friendly nature from SCP Explained!